Julie it's Ross Tucker filling in for
Dan today here on the Dan Patrick show I
don't know how much you caught of what
we were just talking about but does it
bother you does it bother the the girls
on the team you think that hope solo on
some level is by far the most well-known
member of the team well I think probably
the bigger issue is that it takes away
the storylines from the positive stuff
and and that's really probably the
biggest issue is instead of and it feels
like at every world cup or Olympics it's
the case of instead of talking about and
alex Morgan to your point instead maybe
your mom might know or more or Carly
Lloyd's goals or whatever it is we're on
an issue that is more negative and the
centered around hook solo so I think
that gets probably frustrating I know it
certainly gets frustrating for me having
you know as a job having to talk about
it is she that good Julie I mean is you
know in the NFL or whatever they
tolerate guys based on their talent
level is she that good that she's
worthless she's very good and you know
this is actually the first tournament
where you if you rewind to last summer
in the 2015 women's world cup which the
u.s. of course one you know she has a
blinder of a game a great game and their
opening match against australia and the
opening few games when the u.s. is
really struggling and and hope and
defensive back line i mean just not hope
but her back line keeps the u.s. in that
world cup so then when they finally get
their offense together they end up
getting it all together and winning the
world cup but that's been the biggest
difference and it's been the biggest ? i
think for the coaching staff for us
soccer's is you know how much do you put
up with and how much of a distraction is
it and how much is she worth it on the
field and i think that honestly is going
to be the bigger question going forward
is you know as a player as a leader
now that she's obviously taken over more
of a leadership role with this equal
rights equal pay stuff is that is that
worth it or the time to turn the page do
you think there's any truth to her
comments Julie about the way sweet
played specifically at the end seemingly
you know playing for penalty kicks no no
not an onion that's why there's been
such a reaction to call what Sweden did
cowardly is silly really because it's
what it's a tactic that teams take all
the time and soccer it's not a new thing
it's when you know it's very common when
you're outmatched you play more
conservative style you play compact you
bunker in a bit and then you spring out
of it with counter-attacks I mean look
at you know Jose Mourinho one of the
most famous coaches and successful
coaches ever that's what he played all
the time and it's very common so and
it's not easy it's you have to be
disciplined you have to work really hard
and it's frustrating to play against
which is where her frustration comes
from it's frustrating to lose when a
team sits in like that and you have the
ball the entire game but it certainly is
not cowardly it's smart it's a game plan
that worked and they ended up winning
how big of an upset is this julie huge I
mean us should be treated they should be
them nine out of ten times in my opinion
and in the coach of Sweden p.s tenaga is
the old coach of the United States team
who actually won the last two Olympic
gold medals at the US team so she
clearly knows this us demon has her
number because they just haven't been
able to get by her but collectively I
think Sweden is is an organized team but
they have none of the talent that the US
has and we you know as a team we just
didn't have the players in there that
could break down that organized defense
didn't have the legs for whatever reason
there were some injuries obviously
coming into this world cup with Megan
Rapinoe and Carli Lloyd was out for
three months but that's a team that the
US should be and that's why this one's
going to burn finishing up with julie
foudy she's a soccer analyst for ESPN
you know during one of the brakes Julie
one of the day Annette's brought up the
fact that you know after Hope Solo made
those comments nobody was talking about
the coach anymore nobody's talking about
Kristin pressie who missed the kick
Chris impressed I'm sorry who missed the
kick I'm not saying that what Hope Solo
did was calculated I doubt it but was
there some benefit from her saying what
she said to take some heat off of her
teammates and coaches no I don't think
so I don't think calling another team
cowards is beneficial in any way and
especially you know our long-standing
tradition with the team and going back
to us old bags on the team for many
years has been you know you lose with
respect and as painful as it may be our
message to young kids is look we lose
with respect and we shake their hands
and we're good sports and and you do it
with grace and class and so I don't I
don't think that's a benefit I think
it's healthy to be talking about you
know what needs to get better with the
women's team and with all the planners
and funding and support we have in this
country we should be winning every
single world title or Olympic medal so
that that makes me sad that we're not
taking a deeper dive and discussing that
yeah I bet you and and and and the girls
you played with probably get so
frustrated sometimes knowing the way it
used to be you know back in the 80s and
90s and the way it is now for them where
they can you know make pretty good
careers out of it and be pretty well
known that I that must drive you crazy
no no it doesn't i think it's great to
be able to make i mean that's what we
fought for for them to be able to make
what they're making and and have a great
livelihood and and and continue to
progress the game and grow it so that
the next generation has more opportunity
so actually we love to see them you know
being successful in winning games and so
and making you know as much as they
deserve so and that's what that's what
hurts too is like you get knocked out of
the quarter-final the US team has never
lost before the semis we've always been
on the podium so that one
the killer as well yeah I guess I meant
maybe not appreciating what they have is
much given what you guys did Julie
really appreciate the time thanks so
much all right no problem thank you the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience